I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, everybody. Welcome today. We are talking about the injury. Good morning. And you know what? Angela has an injury. I do. I do, speaking of injuries. Guys, I was driving yesterday and I was chewing a piece of gum. I was popping my gum. And I bit the shiitake out of my tongue. It's so bad. Look at it. No, it's really bad. It's a Wraith bump.
我是詹娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作《办公室》的终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。欢迎来到今天的节目。我们在谈论伤势。大家早。你知道吗？安吉拉受伤了。是的。我确实受伤了，说到伤病。伙计们，我昨天在开车，当时正在嚼口香糖。我在吹泡泡糖。结果我狠狠地咬到了舌头。太严重了。你看。不，真的很严重。是个大肿包。
I keep bumping it when I talk. So it's super intense. It's really painful. So if during this podcast, all of a sudden I go, it's because I've bonked it. Yeah. What's wrong with me? I can't chew gum and drive. I was like, I was on the phone with Josh. I was like, another thing. Oh my God. It's really bad. I know. It really hurts. Okay. This episode was written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Brian Gordon. It is season two, episode 12. Wow. Yeah. So we're on the second half of season two now. There were 22 episodes in season two. We've done 18 podcasts. Yeah. When we hit 20, let's have a party. Okay. Like I don't know. Like I'll bring cupcakes or something. Why 20? I don't know. I think we should have
我说话时总是会碰到它。所以感觉非常强烈。真的很疼。所以在这次播客录制期间，如果我突然叫出声，那是因为我撞到它了。是啊。我这是怎么了？我不能一边嚼口香糖一边开车。我当时……我正在和乔什通电话。我说，还有一件事。噢天哪。真的很严重。我知道。真的很痛。好的。这一集是由敏迪·卡林编剧，布赖恩·戈登执导的。这是第二季第十二集。哇。是的。所以我们现在进入第二季的后半段了。第二季一共有22集。我们已经做了18期播客了。是的。等我们做到第20期时，我们开个派对吧。好吧。就像我不知道。我会带杯子蛋糕什么的。为什么是20？我不知道。我觉得我们应该
a party one week for casino night. End of season two. Let's have a party for number 23. Let's have a party every time. Random numbers. I don't need a reason to have a party. That's right. Let me do a summary. I can't even, I just start to look at my summary that I've written and it makes me laugh. This is one of your very favorite episodes. People should know that. You bought a shirt, Jenna, because of this episode and you wore it all the time. I bought it off Etsy. It was a foot and a grill. And a grilled foot. It was like a comic book strip of a person grilling their foot. I mean, okay, here it is. Here's the summary. I can't even say it. It's so funny to me. Michael accidentally steps on his George Foreman grill,
为“赌场之夜”举办一次派对。第二季结束了。我们为第23集办个派对吧。每次都办派对。随意的数字。我不需要理由去办派对。没错。让我做个总结。我简直……我刚开始看自己写的总结，就忍不住笑出来。这是你最喜欢的剧集之一。大家应该知道这一点。詹娜，因为这一集你买了一件衬衫，而且你经常穿它。我是从Etsy上买的。上面是一个脚和一个烤架。还有一个烤熟的脚。就像是一个人烤自己的脚的连环画。我是说，好吧，在这里。这是总结。我甚至说不出口。我觉得太搞笑了。迈克尔不小心踩到了他的乔治·福尔曼烤架上，
injuring his foot. It's so funny. Dwight attempts to rescue Michael and crashes his car into a pool, causing what we will find out to be a concussion. During the workday, the staff does not do it on Michael as he had expected. And Dwight's concussion sparks an unexpected friendship with Pam. Aw, you guys must have had so much fun doing that. I loved it. I had so many scenes, just me and Rain, and we bonded so much. Whenever you get put in a scene with someone, that means you're going to work with them for about three or four hours that day exclusively. And whenever they're having their conversations about how the scene is going or in the breaks, you get to just chitty chat. You get to just hang out. So I got to chitty chat a lot with Rain,
弄伤了他的脚。太搞笑了。德怀特试图营救迈克尔，结果把车开进了水池里，正如我们后来发现的那样，这导致了脑震荡。在工作期间，员工们并没有像他预期的那样顺着迈克尔。而德怀特的脑震荡引发了他和帕姆之间意想不到的友谊。天哪，你们拍这一段的时候一定觉得很有趣。我超爱。我有好多场景，就我和雷恩，我们感情加深了好多。每当你和某人安排在一起拍戏，就意味着那天你要和他们单独合作大约三到四小时。每当他们在讨论戏该怎么拍或者在休息时，你就可以随便闲聊。你就可以到处闲逛。所以我有很多机会和雷恩闲聊，
but I just love working with Rain. I mean, you were so fortunate. You got to work with him all the time. All the time. All right. Should we get into the fast facts? All right. Fast fact number one, this script was originally going to be called My Grilled Foot. My Grilled Foot. But then they changed it. So this is a standalone comedic episode that does not forward the Jim Pam storyline in any way, which was a little bit controversial because our last episode was Boo's Cruise, which was a huge bombshell confession by Jim to Michael that he is in love or that he has feelings for Pam. And so everyone tuned in to see what was going to happen. And guess what? We did not answer that question in any way. In any way. So I'm sure like the fans were like,
但我就是喜欢和雷恩合作。我是说，你太幸运了。你总能跟他一起工作。总是这样。好了。我们该进入快速事实环节了吗？好的。快速事实一，这个剧本最初打算叫做《我烤熟的脚》。《我烤熟的脚》。但后来他们改了。所以这是一部独立的喜剧剧集，在任何方面都没有推动吉姆和帕姆的故事线，这有点争议，因为我们的上一集是《布尔的游轮》，那是吉姆向迈克尔的一个巨大重磅坦白，说他爱上了帕姆，或者说他对帕姆有感觉。所以每个人都收看节目想看看会发生什么。结果呢？我们完全没有回答那个问题。完全没有。所以我觉得粉丝们当时肯定在想，
what the heck? Yeah, it does move forward. Dwight and Angela a little bit. It does. I have that down. It contains references to the Dwight and Angela love story, which was nice. It was like this. I mean, we'll get to it, but there are some moments in here that I just love. Yeah, with Dwight Angela. I know, me too. This was also our highest rated episode so far. What? Yeah, I think a lot of people tuned in after Boo's Cruise. I think so. And what a great episode though. I mean, I know we didn't maybe give people what they were hoping to see with the cliffhanger, but we, I mean, comedy gold. We gave him comedy gold. Steve is so funny in this. Oh my gosh. He is the worst patient. The worst. And he made me laugh so hard. Fast fact number two,
到底是怎么回事？是的，它确实推动了一点点。德怀特和安吉拉的故事有一点进展。确实如此。我有记录。它包含了对德怀特和安吉拉爱情故事的呼应，这很好。就像这样。我是说，我们待会儿会讲到，但这里面有些时刻我真的很喜欢。是的，关于德怀特和安吉拉的。我知道，我也是。这也是我们迄今为止收视率最高的一集。什么？对，我觉得很多人是在《布尔的游轮》之后收看的。我也这么觉得。不过多棒的一集啊。我是说，我知道我们可能没有给观众带来他们希望在悬念中看到的结局，但是我们，我是说，喜剧黄金。我们给他们带来了喜剧黄金。史蒂夫在这集里太搞笑了。哦天哪。他是个最糟糕的病人。最差劲的。他把我逗得太厉害了。快速事实二，
guest star, Marcus York, played our building manager, Billy Merchant. Now I have to imagine this was a nod to creator of the British office, Steven Merchant. I think that's where we grabbed that last name. Oh yeah. I didn't think about that. Billy Merchant. Yeah. I feel like that's true. I got to talk to Marcus yesterday. Marcus, thanks so much for taking time out of your day. And here are a few things he shared with me. Okay. So he auditioned for Alison, Mindy, and Greg. And he said it went really, really well. He was really excited. You know that moment where you have a great meeting or a great audition. He said that's how it felt. He had been in LA as a working actor for a while. And he said, this is one that I was like, ooh, I think I, I think I
客串演员马库斯·约克饰演了我们的物业经理比利·麦钱特。现在我不得不猜测这是向英国办公室的创作者史蒂夫·麦钱特致敬。我想我们就是从那里借用了这个姓氏。哦是的。我之前没想到这点。比利·麦钱特。对。我觉得确实如此。我昨天跟马库斯聊过。马库斯，非常感谢你百忙之中抽出时间。以下是他跟我分享的一些事。好的。所以他为艾莉森、敏迪和格雷格试镜了。他说进展得非常非常顺利。他真的很兴奋。你知道那种你开了一个很棒的会议或有了一次很棒的试镜的时刻。他说这就是当时的感受。他作为一名职业演员在洛杉矶待了一段时间。他说，这是那种让我觉得，哦，我觉得我，我觉得我
got it. And he said that Greg jumped up and shook his hand. And he was like, okay. And then he was running errands. He was at Home Depot and he got the call that he got it. And his agent was like, you got it. And he was like, wait a second, I'm in Home Depot. I have to call you back. So he said he'll always remember that. And then he said the night before he had to come in, he was nervous and he got like no sleep. He said, I got zero sleep. He said, so then the next day I was freaking out because I hadn't gotten any sleep. And you know, it's like hard to remember your lines or anything. So he was like, I was really trying to wing it. And I said, well, we couldn't tell at all. Like, you were just such a cool customer. You had your lines, you were like totally ready to
稳了的试镜。他说格雷格当时跳起来跟他握了手。他当时想，好吧。然后他去办杂货。他在全美家居建材店（Home Depot）时接到了电话，得知他被选上了。他的经纪人说，你被选中了。而他却说，等一下，我在全美家居建材店。我得回给你电话。所以他说他会永远记住那一刻。然后他说在要来拍戏的前一晚，他很紧张，几乎没睡着觉。他说，我零睡眠。他说，所以第二天我整个人都在抓狂，因为我一觉都没睡。而且你知道的，要记住台词什么的很难。所以他当时说，我真的很努力在即兴发挥。而我说，哦，我们完全看不出来。就像，你完全是个从容不迫的人。你带着台词，完全准备好了
go. He said, Ang, I was like going on no sleep. Oh my God. That happens to me always before a shoot. Yeah, or a big day, right? Like whenever I have a big day, it's hard to sleep. And then he said the thing he wasn't prepared for, and this really made me laugh, he said, the conference room is so small. Yeah. He said it's so small. And he goes, and there were so many of you. It's such a small room. And like him and Steve were at the front of the room having, so we're all looking at them, you know? Yeah. And he said the room was so tiny. And he said, you guys had crammed so many people in there. And that actually really made me laugh. And then the one other thing he said he remembered from the set, A, he said we were all really nice. Oh, that's good. That's good. But he
出发。他说，安吉，我当时真的是熬夜没睡。哦天哪。每次拍戏前我都会这样。是的，或者遇到重要日子的时候，对吧？就像每当我遇到重要的日子，就很难入睡。然后他说他没有准备好的一件事——这真的把我逗笑了——他说，会议室太小了。是的。他说太小了。然后他说，里面有那么多的人。房间实在是太小了。而且他和史蒂夫在房间的前面，所以我们都在看着他们，你知道吗？对。他说房间太迷你了。然后他说，你们竟然在里面塞了那么多的人。这真的把我逗笑了。然后他提到的关于片场的另一件事，A，他说我们人都很好。哦，那挺好。那挺好。但他
also said the food was awesome. Yeah. He said, you guys know you had really good food, right? We did. I was like, yeah, that is true. My dad said the same thing after visiting. He was like, man, the food. We really did. We had really good food. Ah, that is so nice. It was a delight talking to him. And I have a few other things as the episode goes. Okay, I love that. I love that. All right, should we do Fast Facts number three? Do it. I feel like I need to tell you I ran out of Fast Facts for this episode. What? I ran out. This is one of your favorite episodes. I know. How can you, there's only three. There's only three. How do you run out? Well, I did. And you're gonna see, here is all I could come up with. Drum roll. Oh, I can't my tongue out. Oh, injury, injury. Go.
还说食物太棒了。是的。他说，你们知道你们当时的伙食真的很好，对吧？我们确实很好。我就说，对，确实如此。我爸爸在参观之后也说了同样的话。他当时说，天哪，这伙食。我们确实如此。我们当时的伙食真的很好。啊，真是太好了。和他的交谈非常愉快。随着剧情的发展，我还有其他一些事情要说。好的，我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。好了，我们该进行快速事实三了吗？开始吧。我觉得我需要告诉你，这一集的快速事实我用完了。什么？我用完了。这是你最喜欢的剧集之一。我知道。你怎么会，只有三个。只有三个。你怎么能用完呢？好吧，我就是用完了。你会看到的，这就是我能想到的全部。敲鼓。哦，我咬到舌头了。哦，受伤了，受伤了。继续。
We filmed this episode November 2005. I know this because I saved the script and it's typed on the front. Okay, well, listen, as far as your delivery of that Fast Facts, you could have been like, guys, I saved the script. Oh, let me do it again. Are you ready? Here's me. Fast fact number three, I saved the script. Oh my God, that's amazing. Oh yeah, that's good. See you turned it around. That's better. Okay. Yeah. All right. Well, that's it. Let's get into it. Should we start breaking down the episode? We usually take a break first. Okay. We haven't been talking that long. Do you want to take a break? I don't know. It's just what we usually do. I could put some numbing stuff on my tongue. I don't know how that's going to work out for the rest of the episode though.
我们是2005年11月拍摄这一集的。我知道这一点是因为我把剧本保存了下来，上面打字写着日期。好吧，听着，就你刚才说那个快速事实的语气来说，你本可以像这样，伙计们，我保存了剧本。哦，让我再来一次。准备好了吗？看我的。快速事实三，我保存了剧本。哦天哪，太棒了。哦，对，这很好。你看你扭转过来了。这样更好。好的。好吧，就这样。我们切入正题吧。我们要开始剖析这一集了吗？我们通常会先休息一下。好的。我们还没聊那么久呢。你想休息一下吗？不知道。这只是我们通常的做法。我可以在舌头上涂点麻药。不过我不知道这在接下来的一集里会怎么样。
It'd be very interesting. All right, we'll be back to break down the episode. All right, we're back talking about the injury. Angela has an injury. Let's get started. This episode opens with what I believe is one of the greatest scenes ever in a television comedy. And I feel similarly about the opening scene of Fleabag season two as I feel about this. I haven't seen season two of Fleabag. Sorry, is this going to be a problem in your friendship? Wait, is this a Game of Thrones moment for you? Yeah, I told you to watch it. Okay, so I watched the first episode of Fleabag season one. Yeah. I told you to just start with season two. Well, I don't want to start out of order. I get that. I get that. I get that. But I just need you to watch season two of Fleabag
那会非常有趣。好的，我们稍后回来剖析这一集。好的，我们回来了，继续谈论伤势。安吉拉受伤了。我们开始吧。这一集的开场是我认为电视喜剧中有史以来最棒的场景之一。我对《伦敦生活》第二季开场镜头的感受也和这个差不多。我没看过《伦敦生活》第二季。抱歉，这会成为你们友谊的问题吗？等等，这对你来说是个《权力的游戏》时刻吗？对啊，我叫你看的。好吧，我看了《伦敦生活》第一季的第一集。对。我让你直接从第二季开始看。嗯，我不想不按顺序看。我懂的。我懂的。我懂的。但我需要你看《伦敦生活》第二季，
because I had like an epiphany while watching it, and it changed my life. And I think it's like the greatest season of television ever made. Okay, I will, I want to watch it. I will watch it. I don't believe you. I don't believe you. I think if you wanted to watch it, you would have watched it by now. When do you watch television? I fall asleep. Like I try to put the kids to bed. Okay, we're getting off track. I, we, Lee and I watch about 45 minutes of television each night after we get the kids down and after we, like, after I play freesale on my phone and he plays online poker. Oh, I'm getting, by the way, I am getting a real window. You are. Then we go downstairs and we watch either half of a movie or a TV show. That's my life, everybody.
因为我在看的时候有了一种顿悟，它改变了我的人生。而且我认为这是有史以来最棒的一季电视剧。好吧，我会的，我想看。我会看的。我不信。我不信。我觉得如果你想看的话，你早就看了。你什么时候看电视？我睡着了。比如我试着哄孩子们睡觉。好吧，我们扯远了。我和李每天晚上在把孩子们哄睡着之后，大概会看45分钟的电视，然后，就像我在手机上玩蜘蛛纸牌，他在玩在线扑克。哦，我正在，顺便说一句，我正在获得一扇真正的窗户。确实如此。然后我们下楼，要么看半部电影，要么看一集电视剧。这就是我的生活，各位。
It's very routine. I like, we'll go a long time without watching television. And then I will have some random day where I just like binge watch three hours of TV. Well, I'm going to clear your schedule for Fleabag season two. All right, it's going to change your life. Yeah, that's right. Sometimes you have to get bossy about things. And this is okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. All right. Back to our show called The Office. This opening scene, it opens with just shots of general office life. Michael is not in the office. And apparently that has put all of us in a good mood because we're all just milling about chatting with one another when suddenly the phone rings. Pam answers the phone. And this is when Michael explains that he's hurt. He needs Pam to pick
非常有规律。我喜欢，我们会隔很长时间不看电视。然后我就会有个随机的日子，一口气狂看三个小时的电视。好吧，我要帮你把《伦敦生活》第二季的日程排出来。好的，这会改变你的人生。没错。有时你对事情不得不表现得强势一点。这没关系。好的。好的。好的。好吧。回到我们的节目《办公室》。这个开场镜头，它以日常办公室生活的几个镜头开场。迈克尔不在办公室里。显然这让我们所有人的心情都很好，因为我们都在闲逛，互相聊天，突然电话铃响了。帕姆接了电话。就在这时，迈克尔解释说他受伤了。他需要帕姆去接他。
him up. Jim puts him on speakerphone. The only person willing to rescue him is Dwight, who runs out of the building and crashes his car. So I have the script. And as I was watching this, I mean, I watched the scene, then I called Leon, he had just gotten out of the shower. I was like, I was like, he was dripping wet. And I'm like, you have to come in and watch the scene with me again, because it's so good. He's like, okay, can I try off first? Like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, but you have to watch this brilliant bit of television comedy. So then I watched it again. I must have watched this five times. That whole insane conversation was totally scripted. Line for line. That opening scene is not improvised. It's awesome. That is crazy to me. The only thing
吉姆把他按在免提电话上。唯一愿意去救他的人是德怀特，他跑出大楼并把车撞了。我有剧本。当我观看这一幕时——我是说，我看了这个场景，然后我打电话给李，他刚洗完澡。我说，我当时说，他全身湿漉漉的。我说，你必须进来和我一起再看一遍这个场景，因为太棒了。他说，好吧，我能先擦干吗？我说，行，行，行，行，但你必须看这段精彩绝伦的电视喜剧。于是我又看了一遍。我大概看了五遍。那段疯狂的对话完全是按剧本来的。台词一字不差。那个开场镜头不是即兴发挥的。太棒了。这对我来说太疯狂了。唯一
that wasn't in the script was when Michael said he had a protuberance on his elbow. In the script, it just said hurt my elbow. And that was the only improv. But that also shows that how ready John, as Jim was the minute Michael said that it wasn't in the script, John looked to camera like, okay. Yeah. I mean, what is happening there? It's great. It's fantastic. So good. Now listen, my folks who love the background at the very top where we're all just milling about before the phone call happens. Yeah. I am totally not in character. Oh, I saw it. I am just being me. You and Brian are in the background over Oscar's shoulder. We're goofing off. Brian, I remember did some silly like, and I swat him. Yeah. But as me, I laugh. I laugh and swat him.
不在剧本里的，是迈克尔说他手肘上有一个突起。剧本里只写了弄伤了我的肘部。那是唯一的即兴发挥。但这同时也表明，当迈克尔说出那句不在剧本里的台词时，约翰饰演的吉姆反应有多快，约翰看着镜头，仿佛在说，好吧。我是说，那里面发生了什么？太棒了。太精彩了。太好了。现在听着，我那些喜欢在电话打响前我们都在闲逛的背景镜头的粉丝们。是的。我完全没有进入角色。哦，我看到了。我只是在做我自己。你和布赖恩在奥斯卡肩膀后面的背景里。我们在胡闹。我记得布赖恩做了一个傻乎乎的动作，然后我拍了他一下。是的。但作为我自己，我笑了。我笑了并拍了他一下。
I totally saw it. It's totally me. Well, the thing is, is that Oscars out of focus and you guys are in focus in the background, you probably thought you were safe. We probably thought the camera was on Oscar, but no, the focus was on you. Yeah. We didn't know we were on camera. I saw that. That's a really good one. That happens at five seconds. Jenna, I have a question for you. What? At 27 seconds. What? You're starting to break. I see you starting to break. Yes. I don't think so. Oh my God. Totally. And then later. What am I doing? What is happening at 27 seconds? It's got to be the phone call. I don't know. I didn't write it down. I should have written it down. How do you know I'm not acting? Everybody thought I was breaking when Dwight was in the
我完全看到了。那完全是我。好吧，问题是，奥斯卡失焦了，而你们在背景里是对焦的，你们可能觉得自己很安全。我们可能以为镜头在奥斯卡身上，但并没有，焦点在你们身上。是的。我们不知道我们在镜头里。我看到了。那真的很好。在五秒钟的时候发生了。詹娜，我有个问题问你。什么？在27秒的时候。什么？你开始笑场了。我看到你开始笑场了。是的。我不这么觉得。哦天哪。完全是。然后过了一会儿。我在干什么？27秒的时候发生了什么？肯定是因为那个电话。我不知道。我没记下来。我早该记下来的。你怎么知道我没有在演戏？所有人都以为当德怀特在
box. Well, I think you're starting to break, but guess what? What? Later on, you full-on break. I full-on break in the conference room. I know. Okay. But anyway, at 27 seconds, it looks like you're starting to break. Okay. I might be. At 47 seconds, we present the greatest talking head of all time, Michael's talking head explaining how he burned his foot. This too is word for word from the script. Sam, I am going to need you to pull this up. Michael explains that he loves to wake up to the smell of bacon, and then he explains how he makes that happen, and it involves a George Foreman grill on the floor of his bedroom. Six strips of bacon. It's brilliant, but Steve's delivery of it. He is so, it's like, I feel like his intention
盒子里时我在笑场。嗯，我觉得你开始笑场了，但是猜怎么着？什么？稍后，你彻底笑场了。我在会议室里彻底笑场了。我知道。好吧。总之，在27秒时，看起来你好像开始笑场了。好吧。我可能是。在47秒时，我们呈现了史上最棒的访谈镜头，迈克尔解释他是怎么烧伤他的脚的。这也是剧本里的原话。萨姆，我需要你把这个调出来。迈克尔解释说他喜欢伴着培根的香味醒来，然后他解释他是怎么做到这一点的，这需要在他的卧室地板上放一个乔治·福尔曼烤架。六条培根。这太绝了，但是史蒂夫的演绎。他太，就好像，我觉得他的意图是，好吧，让我再向你解释一遍。
is like, okay, let me explain it to you again. For everyone who can't seem to understand, one last time. Right. And then also that it's like the most normal thing ever. Yeah. Like, I don't, what is confusing about this? Do I need to tell you how, okay, this is how you shower. Yes. Okay, Sam, you have to find it. It's at 47 seconds. I enjoy having breakfast in bed. I like waking up to the smell of bacon. Sue me. And since I don't have a butler, I have to do it myself. So most nights before I go to bed, I will lay six strips of bacon out on my George Foreman grill. Then I go to sleep. When I wake up, I plug in the grill. I go back to sleep again. Then I wake up to the smell of crackling bacon. It is delicious. It's good for me. It's a perfect way to start
给所有似乎无法理解的人，最后一次。对。而且这就像是最正常不过的事情一样。是的。就像，我不，这有什么好困惑的？我需要告诉你怎么，好吧，这就是你洗澡的方式吗？是的。好吧，萨姆，你得把它找出来。在47秒。我喜欢在床上吃早餐。我喜欢伴着培根的香味醒来。告我吧。既然我没有管家，我只能自己动手。所以在我睡觉前的绝大多数夜晚，我会把六条培根摆在我的乔治·福尔曼烤架上。然后我睡觉。当我醒来时，我插上烤架。我又回去睡觉。然后我伴着滋滋作响的培根香味醒来。太美味了。对我有好处。这是开始一天的完美方式。
today. Today I got up, I stepped onto the grill and I clamped down on my foot. That's it. I don't see what's so hard to believe about that. It's so good. It's so good. It's so good. Since I don't have a butler. Since I don't have a butler, like everybody else who wants bacon in the morning, all of the eye rolling too that he's doing, it's just like, oh, well, he loves breakfast in bed. He loves it. This is what you have to do. Oh my gosh. I just think it's, I just think it's amazing. I have a- It's good for me. It's healthy. It's six strips of bacon every day. I don't know. Fan question from C. Was Steve actually on the other end of the line during the filming of the phone call? Yes. A lot of people wrote in to ask, how do we do these phone calls? We've talked a
今天我起床了，我踩到了烤架上，把我的脚夹住了。就是这样。我不明白这有什么难以置信的。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。既然我没有管家。既然我没有管家，就像其他所有早上想吃培根的人一样，他还在不停地翻白眼，这就像是，哦，好吧，他喜欢在床上吃早餐。他超爱。这就是你必须做的。哦天哪。我只是觉得这，我只是觉得太惊艳了。我有——对我有好处。很健康。每天六条培根。我不知道。来自C的粉丝提问。在拍摄电话通话时，史蒂夫真的在线路的另一端吗？是的。很多人写信来问，我们是怎么打这些电话的？我们之前讨论过
little bit about it before. Usually they just would have someone very close off camera. Like in another room. Yeah. Like when we did scenes with Melora, she was usually just in the conference room calling in to Steve's office. I don't know where they put Steve here, but he was there. It was live. We could, you know, when he said protuberance, John could react. That is fantastic. I have a question for you. So during this whole exchange, we cut back to Pam's desk area. So at around 37 seconds, Jenna, there's an I heart you pillow. There's like a red Valentine's bear. What's up? What's up? This isn't the Valentine's episode. What's going on? I don't know. I had those same things. I noticed that, yes, at 37 seconds,
一点。通常他们只会让某个人在离镜头非常近的地方。比如在另一个房间里。对。就像我们和梅洛拉拍对手戏时，她通常就在会议室里给史蒂夫的办公室打电话。我不知道他们把史蒂夫放在哪儿了，但他就在那儿。那是实时的。我们可以，你知道的，当他说出“突起”这个词时，约翰可以做出反应。太棒了。我有一个问题要问你。所以在整个对话过程中，镜头切回了帕姆的办公桌区域。所以在37秒左右，詹娜，有一个“我爱心你”的枕头。有一个红色的情人节小熊。怎么回事？怎么回事？这不是情人节那一集啊。怎么回事？我不知道。我也有那些东西。我注意到了，是的，在37秒时，
there's a really great shot on my desk. What's up with that? I also have a yoga card. Well, I gave that to you. You did? Yes. That's from you? That's from me. So I have, that's one of my cards for today. So I had written you a card. I had bought those little yoga cards at Target. You know, you can get like a pack of tin. Yeah. And she was had like a little pink outfit on. And so I had written you a card on that and you kept it and you had it on your desk. You know, that is so sweet. I noticed I had three post-it notes on my desk as well. And I kept trying to pause and zoom in because I just assumed that those were probably from you too, because you used to pass me post-it that I would put on my desk. The card is from me and you kept
我的办公桌上有一个非常棒的特写。这是怎么回事？我还有一张瑜伽卡。哦，那是送给你的。你送的？对。那是你送的？那是我送的。所以我有，那是今天的卡片之一。所以我曾经给你写过一张卡片。我在塔吉特买过那些小瑜伽卡。你知道的，你可以买到一包十张的那种。是的。上面有一个穿着粉红色衣服的小人儿。所以我当时在上面给你写了一张卡片，你留着它，把它放在你的办公桌上。你知道的，太甜了。我注意到我的办公桌上也有三张便利贴。我一直试图暂停并放大，因为我只是以为那些可能也是你写的，因为你以前经常递给我便利贴，然后我把它们贴在办公桌上。卡片是我送的，你留着
it and you had it on your desk. That is too cute. And it wasn't for anything in particular. It was just, I just had written you a little card about like I was just, I had become a series regular and we were so excited and I just wrote a little card about just like I was so excited that we could have our lunches and all that stuff. You guys, this is an Angela thing you should know. You still do that to this day. You, you love these little cards. It's so cute. And you are very good at handwriting. Just messages of gratitude. Mostly like I'm so, I have so many from you. I'm so grateful for this friendship and it's the sweetest thing about you. Oh, thanks. Yeah, you're really good at that. I put a note in my daughter's lunch a lot and I made one this morning.
它，把它放在你的办公桌上。太可爱了。而且并不是为了什么特别的事情。它只是，我只是给你写了一张小卡片，内容大致是我刚成为了剧组常驻演员，我们超级兴奋，然后我写了一张小卡片，表达我非常高兴我们能一起吃午饭以及所有这些事情。各位，这是安吉拉的一个特点，你们应该知道。你至今仍然保留着这个习惯。你，你很喜欢这些小卡片。太可爱了。而且你的字写得很好。全都是感激的信息。大部分都是，我，我有好多你写的。我太感激这段友谊了，这是你身上最甜美的事情。哦，谢谢。是的，你真的很擅长这个。我经常在女儿的午餐盒里放一张便条，我今天早上就做了一个。
I drew a little palm tree and a beach because she loves the beach and I just have a great day. That's a very sweet thing about you, Angela. Well, thank you. But now looking back, I'm sure like the yoga card must have been weird, but I guess I probably just thought they were cute. No, I think because I did yoga. Didn't I do yoga? You did yoga and you brought me to a yoga class and it was one of the most painful experiences of my life, which is, wait, but to be fair, to be fair, I had brought you to what I thought was a beginner yoga class. Well, first of all, you're like, Angela, go to yoga with me. And I said, Jenna, I've never been to yoga. I don't really get it. I'm not, I don't understand it. I don't know what any of it means. I'd have to go
我画了一棵小棕榈树和一个海滩，因为她喜欢海滩，我就写了祝你有美好的一天。这是你身上非常可爱的一点，安吉拉。好吧，谢谢你。但现在回想起来，我确信那张瑜伽卡一定很奇怪，但我想我当时可能只是觉得它们很可爱。不，我觉得是因为我练瑜伽。我没练过瑜伽吗？你练过瑜伽，你还带我去上过瑜伽课，那是我一生中最痛苦的经历之一，等等，但公平起见，公平起见，我带你去的是我认为适合初学者的瑜伽课。好吧，首先，你当时说，安吉拉，跟我去练瑜伽吧。我说，詹娜，我从来没练过瑜伽。我其实不太懂。我不，我不理解。我不知道这到底是什么意思。我得去
to a beginner beginner. Yeah. And you were like, I've got it. It's amazing. Yeah. There's this one on Tuesdays. We'll go to this beginner yoga class. It'll be terrific. We waited for a day off. You took me to that yoga class. It was not the beginner class. It was so not beginner. And there's woman was like militant. I thought yoga was like supposed to be like a peaceful stretch. She was like that. Like she was yelling and then she got mad at me. It was like an intermediate flow class for anyone who does yoga. And she was like basically speaking a different language. It was like shavasanas and stuff like that. I don't know what that means. I didn't know what that means. And she got really annoyed with me. Do you remember? I do. And I felt really protective of
初学者中的初学者班。对。而你当时说，包在我身上。太棒了。每周二都有这个课。我们会去上这个初学者瑜伽课。一定棒极了。我们等了一个休息日。你带我去了那节瑜伽课。那根本不是初学者课。绝对不是初学者。里面的那个女教练就像个军事教官。我以为瑜伽应该是一种平静的拉伸。她不是那样的。她一直在大喊大叫，然后她对我生气了。对于任何练瑜伽的人来说，那是介于初级和中级之间的流动瑜伽课。她说的基本是另一种语言。全是“尸体放松式”之类的话。我不知道那是什么意思。我不知道那是什么意思。她对我很恼火。你还记得吗？我记得。而且我当时特别想保护
you because and I was there. We started giggling. Yeah. Oh, and then she really didn't like that. No. But I was, I just kept thinking the whole time, what the heck? This is explain, explain. This is beginner. But if anyone knows like yoga flow, they just shout out the poses and it goes really fast. And they don't even explain what they are. And I kept raising my hand. And you're like, and I just, I was so mad. And afterwards I was, oh, I was so fired up to complain because here I had finally convinced you to go to a yoga class with me. I knew this would never happen again after this debacle. And it turns out I read the schedule wrong. And it was in fact an intermediate flow class. I mean, that's what it was. When you realized that, do you remember
你，因为我当时在场。我们开始咯咯笑。是的。哦，然后她真的很讨厌那样。不。但我当时，我整个过程一直在想，到底怎么回事？这是解释，解释一下。这是初学者水平吗？但如果有人了解瑜伽流动课程，他们就会大声喊出体式名称，而且节奏非常快。他们甚至不解释这些体式是什么。我一直在举手。而你说，而且我当时，我真的超级生气。事后我，哦，我当时气得直想投诉，因为我好不容易才说服你跟我去上瑜伽课。我知道经历这场惨败之后，这种事绝对不会再发生了。结果证明我把时间表看错了。那其实是一节中级流动瑜伽课。我是说，事实就是这样。当你意识到这一点时，还记得
what you did? No. You started laughing. You started laughing so hard. You were like, Oh, sorry. I was like, Oh my God. But then there was a pose. Wait, you guys have to do if you've never, ever, I'd never been to yoga. There was a pose where they all fricking stood on their head. They put their feet in the air and they rolled up on their shoulders, on their head and neck. I thought I was going to die. Well, I don't know if you remember Angela, but the next day you called me and you said, I can't put my hair in a ponytail because I can't put my arms above my head. I'm so sore. I was so sore. I've never been bent that way. I was so sore. And that's what she said. That's what she said. Oh dear. That was too much. Oh no. But I didn't go to yoga for years. It took
你做了什么吗？不。你开始笑。你笑得前仰后合。你当时说，哦，对不起。我当时想，哦天哪。但后来有一个体式。等等，你们大家如果从来没——我从来没练过瑜伽。有一个体式是他们所有人他妈的都用头倒立。他们把脚举到空中，然后用肩膀、头部和颈部支撑着翻上去。我当时觉得自己快死了。好吧，我不记得你是否还记得，安吉拉，但第二天你打电话给我说，我扎不了马尾辫，因为我抬不起胳膊过头顶。我太酸痛了。我酸痛得要命。我从来没被折腾成那个样子。我太酸痛了。这就是她说的。这就是她说的。天哪。那太夸张了。哦不。但我好多年都没去练瑜伽。我花了
me years to go back to yoga. This is, by the way, I think a fitting tangent, another injury. I know. And might be why I gave you a card with a yoga lady on it. Maybe it was. So also on my desk, no one's going to care about this but me, but you can see this really odd plastic decoration behind my phone. And this decoration was on my desk for the whole nine years. And I don't know what it is. It's like a plastic base with wires coming out of it. And then on top of the wires, there are like these very colorful half spheres and they clang together if you flippity flop them. What is that for? I thought that I was supposed to hold photos. I thought the spheres you put little photos in. No, there's no slot in the spheres. There's no slot in the
好多年才重新开始练瑜伽。顺便说一句，我觉得这是一个恰当的题外话，又是一次受伤。我懂的。这可能就是为什么我送给你一张印有瑜伽女郎的卡片的原因。也许是的。同样在我的办公桌上，除了我自己没人会在乎这个，但你可以看到我的电话后面有一个非常奇怪的塑料装饰品。这个装饰品在我的办公桌上放了整整九年。我也不知道那是什么。它就像是一个塑料底座，上面伸出几根电线。然后在电线的顶端，有一些非常色彩斑斓的半球体，如果你拨弄它们，它们就会撞击在一起。那是用来干什么的？我以为那是用来夹照片的。我以为那些半球体是用来放小照片的。不，半球体上没有缝隙。半球体上没有缝隙。
spheres. No slot in the spheres. No. Okay. Well, I don't know what it is. If anyone wants to go to 37 seconds and look at the shot of my desk and write in and tell me what I was supposed to do with that thing on my desk, please. I thought maybe it held messages. I don't know. Why would anyone want that thing? It's the same as that click-clack thing that we talked about, the Newton's logic. What's it called? They're called the Newton's cradle. A Newton's cradle. Newton's ball. Newton's cradle. Well, it's the same as this weird plasticky thing if you ask me. Okay, let me break down the car crash for everybody. Okay. Fan question, Daly Burnin said, how did Dwight driving into the pole work? Was he driving or was it someone else? I reached out to Rainn Wilson to get the full
半球体上没有缝隙。没有。好吧，我不知道那是什么。如果有人想倒回去看37秒时我办公桌的特写，写信告诉我，我本来应该用我桌上的那个东西干什么的话，请告诉我。我以为它可能是用来夹留言的。我不知道。为什么会有人想要那种东西？它和我们讨论过的那个咔哒咔哒的东西是一样的，就是牛顿摆。叫什么来着？它们叫牛顿摆。牛顿球。牛顿摆。好吧，如果你问我的话，它和那个奇怪的塑料小玩意儿是一样的。好的，我来为大家剖析一下车祸。好的。粉丝提问，戴利·伯宁说，德怀特撞电线杆是怎么拍的？他是自己开的还是别人开的？我联系了雷恩·威尔逊，想要了解这件事的完整
story on this. What did my tall geeky man love of my life say? Here's what he said. He said, if you notice, you never actually see the crash. No. You just hear it. So they just put the car there and he just staggered out of it. Later when he's driving away, that was a stunt driver, Rainn never actually drove the car. Another fan question from Nicholas Powell, what did Rainn Wilson use for his throw up on the car? Cream of potato soup. And Rainn told me it was actually his idea to throw up across the back windshield in the script and on the day he was directed to throw up on the pavement outside of the car, but he thought it would be funnier if he threw up across the back windshield. They only did about two takes, but he said he really hurt his
故事。我生活中那个高高瘦瘦的书呆子挚爱是怎么说的？他是这么说的。他说，如果你注意的话，你其实永远看不到撞车过程。没有。你只能听到声音。所以他们只是把车停在那里，他踉踉跄跄地从车里出来。后来他开车离开时，那是特技替身司机，雷恩其实根本没开车。另一个来自尼古拉斯·帕尔的粉丝提问，雷恩·威尔逊在车上吐的时候用的是什么？奶油土豆汤。雷恩告诉我，其实是他自己提议把呕吐物吐在后挡风玻璃上的。剧本里和拍摄当天，导演原本要他在车外的路面上呕吐，但他觉得如果把呕吐物吐在后挡风玻璃上会更有趣。他们只拍了大约两次，但他说在假装呕吐时他真的把
neck during the fake throw up. Yeah, because he said he had to like project. Yeah, he had to like propel his neck forward so that the vomit would really splatter. And he said it was sore for like two weeks afterwards. So he got Rainn Wilson got an injury filming the injury. Sorry, this is like the kind of stuff when I always felt like as a cast and as a show, we didn't travel well. Like we'd be like, safety meeting, right? We have a candle, we have fake throw up. And then there's other shows with like, you know, insane explosions and car chases, but we get an injury from fake vomiting. We did, he did. I'm sorry, Rainn. All right, so the next thing that happens is that Michael enters on crutches and he has his foot in bubble wrap. And fan question Nathan
脖子弄伤了。是的，因为他说他必须得做出向前喷射的动作。是的，他必须让脖子向前冲，这样呕吐物才能真正溅开。他说之后的两周左右脖子都酸痛。所以雷恩·威尔逊在拍摄“受伤”这一集时真的受伤了。抱歉，每当这个时候，我都觉得作为演员和剧组，我们的安全意识不太行。就像我们会说，安全会议，对吧？我们有一支蜡烛，我们有假呕吐物。然后还有其他剧集有疯狂的爆炸和汽车追逐，而我们的伤病却来自于假呕吐物。确实如此，他真的受伤了。对不起，雷恩。好了，接下来的情节是迈克尔拄着拐杖进来了，他的脚上缠着气泡膜。粉丝提问南森
Jasper asked, was John popping the bubble wrap cast scripted or was that John's idea? It was scripted. It was scripted. I have a question for you, Jenna, speaking of bubble wrap. Yeah. Not too long ago, you injured your foot. I did. Hiking, right? weren't you hiking and you hurt your foot? Yeah, I did. And then you started wearing this big boot around. But then the boot started rubbing your shin. And then one day you showed up and I could hear like yeah. And I said, what is that noise? And I looked down at your boot and sticking out from your boot is bubble wrap. Yeah. So these boots, they have these like metal rods in them, which are what keep your foot stable, right? And they was like pressing into my shin. And I complained about
贾斯珀问，约翰捏气泡膜石膏是剧本里写好的，还是约翰自己的主意？是剧本写好的。是剧本写好的。詹娜，我有个问题想问你，说到气泡膜。嗯。不久前，你的脚受伤了。是的。去徒步旅行，对吧？你是不是去远足然后弄伤了脚？是的，我受伤了。然后你开始穿着这个大靴子到处走。但后来靴子开始磨你的小腿。然后有一天你出现时，我听到类似的声音。我说，那是什么声音？我低头看你的靴子，从你的靴子里露出了气泡膜。是的。所以这些靴子里面有金属杆，那是用来保持脚部稳定的，对吧？它们一直在压迫我的小腿。我在Instagram上抱怨过
it on Instagram. I just said, anyone who's ever worn these, like how did you make these comfortable? Because I'm, it's like my foot feels better. But now my shin, I feel like I'm bruising my bone of my shin. Someone jokingly wrote back and said you should wrap it in bubble wrap like Michael. And I was like, well, I mean, that's not a bad idea. And it worked. It was so effective. Hot tip. Anyone who has to wear a boot, just wrap your shin in bubble wrap. Thank you, Michael Scott. Thank you, Michael Scott. Thank you, the injury. Angela, I am very surprised that you are not calling out a PAMSAS moment. Um, what does this card say? No, I have a previous PAMSAS. Where? No, I didn't tell them you cooked your foot. That is really good.
这件事。我只是说，任何穿过这些靴子的人，你们是怎么把它们穿得舒服的？因为我觉得我的脚感觉好多了。但现在我的小腿，我觉得我的小腿骨都要被撞青了。有人开玩笑地回复我说，你应该像迈克尔一样用气泡膜把它包起来。然后我想，嗯，这倒是个不错的注意。而且真的很有用。实用小贴士。任何需要穿这种靴子的人，只要用气泡膜把小腿包起来就行了。谢谢你，迈克尔·斯科特。谢谢你，迈克尔·斯科特。谢谢你，《伤势》这一集。安吉拉，我很惊讶你没有指出一个帕姆时刻。嗯，这张卡片上写的是什么？不，我前面有一个帕姆时刻。在哪里？不，我没告诉他们你烤了自己的脚。那真的很好。
I was going to say, there's some PAMSAS in this episode. I have a few. I have a few. Next up, Michael calls PAM into his office to ask for messages. Dwight is fanning Michael's foot with a tiny fan. And then it buzzes his foot. And that was not in the script. That we came up with that on the day. Well, I wrote, Jenna, so when that fan hits his toe, I laughed so hard because Steve's reaction was so hilarious. So good. And I, I, how did you keep a straight face? I didn't. Oh my God. I laughed through that entire scene. Oh my Lord. That made me laugh so hard. Don't give Rainn Wilson a tiny prop. Oh, no. Like, don't give him a keyboard at the dundies. They gave him that as an option to fan Michael's
我正要说呢，这一集里有几个帕姆时刻。我有几个。我有几个。接下来，迈克尔叫帕姆进他的办公室询问留言情况。德怀特正用一个小风扇给迈克尔的脚扇风。然后风扇碰到了他的脚。那可不在剧本里。那是我们在片场临时想出来的。好吧，我写下了，詹娜，当那个风扇碰到他的脚趾时，我笑得前仰后合，因为史蒂夫的反应太搞笑了。太棒了。而且，你怎么能忍住不笑的？我没忍住。哦天哪。我那一整场戏都在笑。天哪。别给雷恩·威尔逊一个小道具。哦，不。就像在“邓迪奖”上别给他键盘一样。他们给了他这个选项来给迈克尔的
foot. And then he just ran with it. It was so good. It's like one of my favorite things. At four minutes, 22 seconds, Michael says, your job is being my friend PAM. Yeah. And I think that's what he really thinks. It's true. And so today, I think one of the reasons he's so grumpy, that was really funny. I mean, grumpy PAM when he's talking about like how grumpy is, is because no one is being his friend in his mind. That's your job. Your job isn't to answer phones. Your job is to be my friend. Be friendly to me. I had a fan question from Tanya Colomarino. When PAM calls Michael fussy, was that scripted? Because it sounds like how I describe my teething babies. It was scripted. And it's perfect. It's perfect. Well, so now we're starting to see clues of Dwight's
脚扇风。然后他直接自由发挥了。太棒了。这简直是我最喜欢的桥段之一。在4分钟22秒时，迈克尔说，你的工作就是做我的朋友，帕姆。是的。我觉得这确实是他心里的想法。确实如此。所以今天，我觉得他之所以这么暴躁，那个真的很好笑。我是说，当他谈到自己有多暴躁时，暴躁的帕姆，是因为在他看来没有人拿他当朋友。那是你的工作。你的工作不是接电话。你的工作是做我的朋友。对我和善一点。我有一个来自塔尼亚·科洛马里诺的粉丝提问。当帕姆说迈克尔像个爱发脾气的婴儿时，那是剧本写好的吗？因为听起来就像我形容我长牙的宝宝那样。那是剧本写的。而且非常贴切。太完美了。好吧，所以现在我们开始看到德怀特
concussion. Yeah. Right? He clearly hit his head really hard. Yeah. And there are going to be little things sprinkled throughout the episode. And one of them is he just loses his train of thought. He starts speaking. He doesn't finish his sentence. Yeah. Right? Then he just starts typing Dwight over and over and over and over again. Then he like raises his hand, but he doesn't know he's raising his hand. Yeah. He calls PAM PAN. Yeah. It's like one of my favorite things. I just thought it was so funny. He's also friendly. He's like really friendly and he's And helpful. Helpful. And then later on he's funny. He gets into like that's what she said joke. He calls Creed dad. Yes. He thinks Creed is his dad. At one point he gets weepy. Yeah.
脑震荡的蛛丝马迹了。是的。对吧？他显然头部受到了重击。是的。而且这一集里会穿插一些小细节。其中之一就是他开始思路中断。他开始说话。但他没把话说完。是的。对吧？然后他开始一遍又一遍地敲击“德怀特”这个词。然后他举起了手，但他自己却不知道在举手。是的。他把帕姆叫成潘。是的。这简直是我最喜欢的情节之一。我真的觉得太搞笑了。而且他还很友好。他变得超级友好，而且很乐于助人。乐于助人。然后接下来他变得很幽默。他开始开“这就是她说的”那种玩笑。他管克里德叫爸爸。是的。他以为克里德是他爸爸。有一会儿他还哭鼻子了。是的。
This is what happens when Dwight gets a concussion. I have a fan question from Lucy. Was Rainn Wilson actually typing Dwight over and over? Ooh, was he? Yes. I asked Rainn. He said yes. He was really typing Dwight. But that made me think about how a lot of times we would have those prop computer document things that the props department would have some computer programmer coder come up with. So if you did have to type something specific that they were going to show on the screen, you could actually just press anything and then the sentence would come up. I always liked those. They were really fun. Yeah. Or if like PAM had to, I don't know, like if you clicked on certain things, websites would come up, but they were all fake
这就是德怀特脑震荡后的反应。我有一个来自露西的粉丝提问。雷恩·威尔逊当时真的在反复敲打“德怀特”这个名字吗？哦，是吗？是的。我问过雷恩。他说是的。他当时确实在敲打德怀特。但这让我想起，很多时候我们会有那些道具电脑文档，道具部门会找来一些电脑程序员或编写代码的人来弄。所以如果你确实需要输入一些他们要在屏幕上显示的特定内容，你实际上只需随便按任何键，然后句子就会显示出来。我一直很喜欢这些。它们真的很有趣。对。或者如果帕姆必须，我不知道，比如如果你点击某些东西，网站就会弹出来，但它们全都是假
websites. And it was like a movie. It was just like a slide show of documents. And then you would hit escape and it would start over for the next take. Yeah. And it wouldn't matter what key you hit. Didn't matter. Didn't matter. But he was really typing Dwight. At five minutes, 44 seconds, you guys, there's now a sofa in the conference room. Yes. Where did this sofa come from? I have that. Okay. And then also, is it the only time there's a sofa ever in the conference room? That I don't know. Okay. But it is the sofa from front reception. And I read the script and this is a description from the script that I absolutely love. So I'm going to read it. It says, so Michael moves into the conference room and it says, Michael is splayed out on a sofa,
网站。这就像是一部电影。它只是一段文档幻灯片。然后你按下退出键，它就会为下一个镜头重新开始。是的。而且你按哪个键都无所谓。无所谓。无所谓。但他确实在输入德怀特。在5分44秒时，大家注意，会议室里多了一张沙发。是的。这张沙发是从哪儿来的？我有记录。好的。而且，这是会议室里唯一一次出现沙发吗？这个我不知道。好吧。但它确实是前台接待处的沙发。我读了剧本，这是剧本里的一段描述，我超级喜欢。所以我来读一下。上面写着，迈克尔搬进了会议室，上面写着，迈克尔呈大字型躺在沙发上，
the one by PAM's desk, which has been moved and is cuddled up under a comforter with his leg elevated. It says, though he made the conference room his bedroom, it's unclear if he's wearing his pants under the comforter. That's something Mindy wrote. So however, I love that though, like however they set that scene, they had to make it so that it was unclear. Yeah, he did. He did walk in though with a duvet comforter and two pillows and then like a few like sort of it looked like aloe vera and like, yes, ointments that he had. All right. A ton of people wrote in about this conspiracy theory that Steve had a prop foot that he propped up on the pillow and they sent these pictures that seem to imply that his body is doing something that
帕姆桌子旁的那一个，它已经被挪过来了，他蜷缩在一张羽绒被下，腿高高抬起。上面写着，虽然他把会议室当成了卧室，但还不清楚他在羽绒被下面有没有穿裤子。那是明迪写的。所以不管怎样，我挺喜欢这一点的，就像他们设计那个场景的方式一样，他们不得不让这一点变得不清楚。是的，他确实这样做了。不过他走进来时确实带了一床羽绒被和两个枕头，然后还有几个类似于芦荟以及类似的东西，没错，他带着的药膏。好吧。很多人写信来讨论这个阴谋论，说史蒂夫有一个道具脚，他把它垫在枕头上，他们发了这些照片，似乎暗示他的身体在做出某种动作
a normal human body couldn't do. No, that's Steve's foot. That is Steve's foot. Yeah. But I got so many emails and so many comments about it. That's crazy. That I started, I mean, we were there. We know there was no fake foot on a pillow. No. But the pictures were so convincing and we'll post this on our website so you can see. They were so convincing that I reached out to Steve. Oh my God, Jenna. I bothered Steve, girl. You were like, Steve, is that your foot? And he's like, what are you talking about? I'm guessing. It was like 11 at night. He's like, first of all, hi, Jenna. I hope you're well. Yeah, that was my foot. I wrote Steve's e-mail message. It was like 11 p.m. I was like, Steve, I feel like I know the answer to this and I sort of explained it.
正常人体无法做到的动作。不，那是史蒂夫的脚。那是史蒂夫的脚。是的。但我收到了太多的电子邮件和太多的评论。太疯狂了。以至于我开始，我的意思是，我们当时就在那里。我们知道枕头上根本没有假脚。没有。但这些照片太有说服力了，我们会把它发到我们的网站上，这样你们就能看到了。它们太有说服力了，以至于我联系了史蒂夫。噢天哪，珍娜。我打扰史蒂夫了，姑娘。你当时就像是，史蒂夫，那是你的脚吗？而他却说，你在说什么呢？我猜。那是晚上11点左右。他说，首先，嗨，珍娜。希望你一切都好。是的，那确实是我的脚。我给史蒂夫发了封电子邮件。那大约是晚上11点。我当时就想，史蒂夫，我觉得我知道答案，我还稍微解释了一下。
And also, I'm not drunk. And he wrote back and he was like, is this what it's come to? No. This is what we talk about on the podcast. And he was like, it was not a fake foot. It was my foot. It was his foot. I even remember him having to go special to hair and makeup because they put those divots on the bottom. The grill marks. The grill marks. That was special effects makeup. Yeah. A lot of people ask how they did that. There's this putty that they use to make those and they glue it on your foot with a special glue. Spearmint glue or something like that. It is called spearmint glue. But then they use this airbrush makeup machine and then to make it blend and then they'll stipple. It's pretty. Highlight on it. It's pretty amazing. Stipple?
而且，我没喝醉。他回信说，事情已经沦落到这种地步了吗？不。这就是我们在播客里谈论的内容。他说，那不是假脚。那是我的脚。那是他的脚。我还记得他不得不专门去发型和化妆部门，因为他们在脚底做了一些凹痕。烤痕。烤痕。那是特效妆。是的。很多人问他们是怎么做到的。他们用一种油灰来制作这些，然后用一种特殊的胶水把它粘在你的留上。留兰香胶水还是别的什么。它确实叫留兰香胶水。但接着他们会用这种喷枪化妆机，然后为了让它融合，他们会进行点涂。这挺不错的。上面的高光。这太神奇了。点涂？
Stipple. That is what it's called. A stipple sponge. It is. Yeah. Did you not take theater makeup 101? Watch yourself. Well, in my theater training, we had to buy a Ben Nye makeup kit, which included a stipple sponge. Well, I was doing comedy. I was doing improv on stage while you were playing with your sponge. Okay. All right. At five minutes, 50 seconds, the prism duro sport. Yeah. Pam's iPod knockoff gift from Roy. That Dwight says is chunkier and more solid than an iPod. Way to go. Way to go, Roy. You get her the cluster ring and then you get her a prism duro sport. Way to go, Roy. So I did a deep dive on the prism duro sport. Lady, me too. Lady, lady. What did you find? Not only what did I find because I know you found it too,
点涂。这就是它的名字。点涂海绵。没错。是的。你没上过戏剧化妆101吗？注意你的言辞。好吧，在我的戏剧培训中，我们得买一个本·奈彩妆盒，里面就包含一个点涂海绵。好吧，我在搞喜剧。当你在玩你的海绵时，我在舞台上表演即兴喜剧。好吧。好吧。在5分50秒时，普里斯姆·杜罗运动版。是的。罗伊送给帕姆的iPod山寨礼物。德怀特说它比iPod更厚实、更扎实。干得好。干得好，罗伊。你先是送了她集群戒指，然后又送了她一个普里斯姆·杜罗运动版。干得好，罗伊。所以我对普里斯姆·杜罗运动版进行了一次深入研究。姑娘，我也是。姑娘，姑娘。你发现了什么？不仅是我发现了，因为我知道你也找到了，
but I printed it out and I brought it. You brought the fake website for the prism duro sport? Okay. First of all, the fake website is called durosport.com. It's still up. You can still find it. These were. Who made it? Our writers. No, they did not. Yes, they did. Our writers took the time to make this. Yes. How? Clearly, they were just having some fun. We should probably talk to them. They made up durosport.com. Then they went one step further and they made a review site that reviewed the prism duro sport and it's called Medialoper. What? I printed out this. I did not find. I printed out the review of the duro sport. Oh, please. It's the prism duro sport 6,000 worst digital audio player ever and it goes on. You guys, this thing is, oh my gosh,
而且我把它打印出来带来了。你把普里斯姆·杜罗运动版的假网站带来了？好吧。首先，这个假网站叫durosport.com。它现在还挂在网上。你依然能找到它。这些是。谁做的？我们的编剧。不，他们没做。不，他们真的做了。我们的编剧花时间做这个。是的。怎么做到的？显然，他们只是在找点乐子。我们可能应该跟他们谈谈。他们捏造了durosport.com。接着他们更进一步，做了一个评论网站来评价普里斯姆·杜罗运动版，名叫Medialoper。什么？我打印了这个。我没有找到。我打印了关于杜罗运动版的评论。噢，拜托。那是普里斯姆·杜罗运动版6000，史上最烂的数字音频播放器，诸如此类。你们这些家伙，这东西，哦天哪，
I printed out, it is 11 pages. Can we put links on our website? Yes, we're on our website. OfficeLadies.com. Look for all this stuff. Look, there's the photo of it. It looks ridiculous, but here's one of my favorite things. At the end of this horrible review, there is a comment board. And they made fake comments. They made fake comments, which is so funny. You have to read the fake comments. They're some of my favorites. And the very, very last fake comment, if you go all the way to the end, it says, it's by Shilkote. Okay. Why do I feel like that's Mike Schur? It says Shilkote says, to anyone who doesn't know, duro sport is in fact a joke. It was created by the writers of the office. Check the who is. It went up soon after the episode air. Wow.
我打印出来了，足足有11页。我们能在网站上放链接吗？可以，就在我们的网站上。OfficeLadies.com。去找找所有这些东西。看，这就是它的照片。它看起来太荒谬了，但这是我最喜欢的事情之一。在这篇糟糕的评论的结尾，有一个评论区。他们编造了假评论。他们编造了假评论，太搞笑了。你们得去看看这些假评论。它们是我最喜欢的一些。而且最后最后的那条假评论，如果你一直拉到最后，上面写着，是Shilkote写的。好吧。为什么我总觉得那是迈克·舒尔？上面写着Shilkote说，对于任何不知道的人来说，杜罗运动版其实是个笑话。它是《办公室》的编剧们创作的。去查查whois信息吧。它在这集播出后不久就上线了。哇。
Our writers were really having a good time with this. I guess so. I have a fan question from Steph. Was Pam's device a creative Zen MP3 player? She calls it something else, but it really looks like a creative Zen. So there is, I mean, Phil Shea had to hand me something, and it really worked. I could really scroll, and it really plugged into my computer. So I froze the image at five minutes, 47 seconds, and I compared it to an image of a creative Zen. I think stuff might be right. Nice catch stuff. I'm giving you applause. Yeah. So I guess if you want to own one, they have them on eBay. Also, fan comment from Jamie Garrett just said comment. This is not a question. I can verify that there was actually a Russian music website with 10 cent downloads.
我们的编剧们这次真的玩得很开心。我猜是的。我有一个来自斯蒂芬的粉丝提问。帕姆的设备是创意科技（Creative Zen）的MP3播放器吗？她叫它别的名字，但它看起来真的很像创意科技。所以，我的意思是，菲尔·谢伊不得不递给我一些东西，而且它真的很好用。我真的可以滚动屏幕，它也真的能插进我的电脑。所以我把画面定格在5分47秒，把它和创意科技的图片进行了对比。我觉得斯蒂芬可能猜对了。干得漂亮，斯蒂芬。我要为你鼓掌。所以我想如果你想拥有一台，他们在eBay上有卖的。还有，来自杰米·加里特的粉丝评论只是说了一条评论。这不是一个问题。我可以证实，确实曾有一个俄罗斯音乐网站提供10美分下载。
I used it for years until sanctions against Russia shut it down. So Dwight is giving Pam some good advice. I totally believe that. At six minutes, 48 seconds, some major Pamsas. Pamsas. Pamsas. Michael's like, will you come in here? And she goes, tell me before I come there. No, that feels like such justified sass. It's justified sass, but it's also how I talk to my children when they're like, Mom, I'm like, what? Tell me if I come all the way upstairs. I want to know what this is about. But then he asked her to rub butter on his foot. Gross. Country Crock. And she just says no and hangs up on him. I had a question about that. Is Country Crock in the script because it sounded like an improv?
我用了好几年，直到针对俄罗斯的制裁把它关停。所以德怀特给了帕姆一些好建议。我完全相信这一点。在6分48秒时，出现了一些重大的帕姆式傲慢。帕姆式傲慢。帕姆式傲慢。迈克尔说，你能不能进来？而她说，在我过去之前先告诉我。不，这感觉像是非常正当的傲慢。这是正当的傲慢，但这也是我对我的孩子们说话的方式，当他们说，妈妈，我就会说，什么？如果我要一路走上楼，先告诉我。我想知道这是为了什么。但接着他让她把黄油抹在脚上。真恶心。乡村白油（Country Crock）。而她直接说不，然后挂断了他的电话。我对此有一个问题。剧本里有乡村白油吗，因为听起来像即兴发挥？
No. Country Crock was not in the script. What happens after Pam hangs up with him is that Meredith was supposed to come over and offer to do it. And Michael says something like, oh, no. And she says, I'm telling you, Michael, I have really soft hands. So there was a little extra little beat. That's what happened after he didn't say Country Crock. Well, when I watched it and Steve as Michael said, Country Crock, you sort of get to know each other and you can sort of tell when something, I was like, that is all Steve. That sounds like an improv to me. So at seven minutes, 31 seconds in the scene at reception when Dwight is showing Pam that she can throw her music thing and it won't break.
没有。乡村白油不在剧本里。在帕姆挂断他的电话之后发生的事情是，梅雷迪思本应该过来主动提出要做这件事。而迈克尔说了一些类似于，哦，不。然后她说，我告诉你，迈克尔，我的手真的很软。所以多了一小段微小的节奏。这就是他在没有说出乡村白油之后发生的事情。好吧，当我观看这一段时，史蒂夫作为迈克尔说出“乡村白油”时，你们开始有点了解彼此了，你就能大致看出什么时候有些事，我当时就想，这全都是史蒂夫。听起来像是即兴发挥。所以在7分31秒时，在接待处的那个场景中，德怀特向帕姆展示她可以扔掉她的音乐设备而且它不会坏。
Did you notice at the end of the scene what Reign as Dwight does? He taps the desk the way Jim always does. Yes, as he walked off. Yeah, that was a little bit that Reign and I came up with on the day. That is so great. That's so subtle. I love it. Yeah, it's really cute. I love it. Well, I have at seven minutes, 38 seconds, is Jim jealous? Jim? So I can't believe it. Jim is a little bit jealous of Dwight because Dwight is having his Pam moments. Yeah, Pam and Dwight are friends now. And at seven minutes, 43 seconds, I have my very famous line that gets quoted to me a lot. Oh my God, Dwight is kind of my friend. How about the scene where Michael is in the conference room and he's on the phone with his mom? It's one of my favorite scenes. It is one of my
你注意到在这个场景结束时，雷恩扮演的德怀特做了什么吗？他像吉姆总是做的那样敲了敲桌子。是的，当他走开的时候。是的，那是雷恩和我当天即兴想出的一个小设计。太棒了。太微妙了。我喜欢。是的，真的很可爱。我喜欢。好吧，在7分38秒，吉姆是在嫉妒吗？吉姆？所以我简直不敢相信。吉姆有点嫉妒德怀特，因为德怀特正在经历他的“帕姆时刻”。是的，帕姆和德怀特现在是朋友了。而在7分43秒，我有我那句非常著名的、经常被人引用的台词。哦天哪，德怀特算是我的朋友。迈克尔在会议室里跟妈妈打电话的那场戏怎么样？这是我最喜欢的场景之一。这绝对是我最
favorite scenes. It is so layered with so much. He's like, no one cares. And then he's sort of like clearly lied to his mom about Jim and Jan. And he's like, oh, she'll have to dry it. She'll worry. And then then he finds out that Pam and his mom have been chatting and Pam has filled in his mom on his relationship status. And he gets so ticked off. I love this whole conversation. It was so great. That was all scripted. Oh, it's so good, Mindy. But look at all the people milling around in the background of that. There were so many crosses. Are we ever up from our desks like that? Why? So much activity. I'm not even at reception. I'm like doing something. What am I doing in that corner? You know what that moment was when I watched it? That's Brian Gordon. I think that's
喜欢的场景之一。里面层层叠叠包含了太多东西。他说，没人会在乎。然后他又有点像是在对妈妈撒谎，关于吉姆和简的事。他说，哦，她得去擦干。她会担心的。然后，然后他发现帕姆和他的妈妈一直在聊天，而且帕姆把他和妈妈聊过他的感情状态的事都告诉了他妈妈。然后他气坏了。我太喜欢整段对话了。太棒了。那全是按剧本演的。哦，太棒了，明迪。但看看背景里那些晃来晃去的人。有那么多人在走动。我们什么时候会那样离开办公桌？为什么？有这么多的活动。我甚至都不在前台。我在做别的。我在那个角落里干嘛呢？你知道当我看到那一幕时觉得那是什么吗？那是布ライ恩·戈登。我觉得那是
the director. And he wanted a bunch of us. Like he wanted movement in the back of the scene. Well, if I remember correctly, there was this idea that he had where because Steve was stuck, he wanted it to seem like that was like a FOMO. Like he wasn't out there with us. He wasn't walking around with us and like joking with us and that he couldn't be part of what that was happening out there. Look at you using the kids lingo. FOMO. FOMO. Is that the kids lingo? A little bit. All right, guys, I'm going to read to you from a journal. I wrote about the scene of Rain and I in the break room. So you're going to hear some journal thoughts from Angela. Journal thoughts after the break. Come on.
导演。他想要我们当中的很多人。就像他想要场景背景中有走动一样。好吧，如果我没记错的话，他当时有一个想法，因为迈克尔被困住了，他想让那种情况看起来像是一种错失恐惧症（FOMO）。就像他没有和我们待在外面一样。他没有和我们一起在外面走动、跟我们开玩笑，而且他无法成为当时在外面发生的事情的一部分。瞧瞧你，用上了年轻人的黑话。FOMO。FOMO。那是年轻人的黑话吗？有一点吧。好了，伙计们，我要给你们读一篇日记。我写的关于雷恩和我呆在茶水间的那个场景的日记。所以你们会听到一些来自安吉拉的日记感想。休息之后的日记感想。来吧。
We're back, everyone, from our break and it's time for Angela's Diary. Every time you say that, she's been saying that during the break, you guys. Angela's Diary. It just sounds like something brought to you by PBS. Angela's Diary. So the scene in the break room with Dwight and Angela. Summed to Angela. Summed to Angela. Some weird love. Well, he tells her that she's sweeter than candy and then he pats her butt. He does. Angela wrote about it in her diary, you guys. I wrote about it in my journal. Your journal. So, all right, I say a few things about that break room scene. Between Dwight and Angela, we filmed a lot of different versions.
欢迎大家从茶歇中回来，现在是“安吉拉日记”时间。每次你这么说，她在茶歇时一直在这么说，伙计们。安吉拉日记。听起来就像是公共广播公司（PBS）播出的节目。安吉拉日记。所以，德怀特和安吉拉在茶水间的那场戏。属于安吉拉。属于安吉拉。某种诡异的爱。好吧，他告诉她她比糖果还要甜，然后他拍了拍她的屁股。他真的这么做了。安吉拉把这写进了她的日记里，伙计们。我把它写进了我的日记里。你的日记。所以，好吧，我针对那个茶水间场景说了一些事情。在德怀特和安吉拉之间，我们拍了许多不同的版本。
Pretty much they just wanted Rain to surprise me in some way and that I would have like this natural reaction. Sure. And we knew that he was going to do something and then kind of run off, right? So I have here, Rain spanked me, swatted me, tried to kiss me. One time he actually picked me up by my butt. Whoa. So I remember he like ran up behind me and kind of grabbed me and I sort of leaned back and he lifted up at the same time. We weren't planning this, guys. This was just like a kind of random accident, but it was so weird that he just sort of lifted me by my buttocks. So that one didn't make it in. Anyway, we did a bunch of takes and I said that I laughed so much. We were laughing so much that I was really surprised they found one they could use
基本上他们只是希望雷恩能以某种方式给我一个惊吓，然后我会做出那种自然的反应。当然。我们知道他会做点什么，然后跑开，对吧？所以我这里写着，雷恩打了我的屁股，扇了我，试图亲我。有一次他居然直接抓着我的屁股把我整个人抱了起来。哇。所以我记得他从我身后跑过来，一把抓住我，我顺势往后一靠，他同时把我举了起来。我们可没计划好这个，伙计们。这只是一次非常随意的意外，但他竟然用这种方式把我从臀部举起来，真是太诡异了。所以那一版没能剪进正片里。不管怎样，我们拍了很多条，我说我笑得太厉害了。我们笑得太厉害了，以至于我真的很惊讶他们居然能挑出一条能用的，
because I didn't know what he was going to do. And you know, Rain, Rain is like going to throw you curveballs. He actually delights in that. Of course. He loves it. He loves to throw you off, but ultimately we use the one where he swatted me a bunch and just ran away. In the script it said he squeezes your butt. Did you do some squeezes? I'm sure. I'm sure there were squeezes swats. I mean, I did write that like I had a little bruise on my butt the next day. That was just too much touching your butt? Anyway, that's what I wrote there. Well, the next scene, Michael is trying to enter the kitchen. Ryan does not help him because he is busy eating string cheese with Toby, which I loved that interaction. I did too.
因为我根本不知道他会做出什么举动。而且你知道的，雷恩，雷恩总是会给你抛出一些意想不到的曲线球。他其实以此为乐。当然。他太喜欢了。他喜欢让你出其不意，但最终我们用的是他狠狠打了我几巴掌然后跑开的那一条。剧本里写的是他捏你的屁股。你们拍的时候有捏屁股吗？我确信。我确信肯定有捏也有拍。我的意思是，我确实写过第二天我的屁股上有个小淤青。那是对你屁股太多的触碰吗？不管怎样，我当时就是这么写的。好吧，接下来的场景，迈克尔试图进入厨房。瑞安没有帮他，因为正忙着和托比一起吃手撕干酪，我太喜欢那个互动了。我也是。
When Ryan's like, oh, you just go for it. You just, you know, you don't pull it apart. I love that. That was actually Toby says that to Ryan. I know you just go for it. Did I say Ryan? Yeah, you said Ryan. Oh, God, I'm so embarrassed. I'm embarrassed for myself. Please, we'll issue a correction. Angela, how do you eat string cheese? Do you go for it or do you string it? I go for it. I string it. Oh, this says everything about us. You probably methodically, you have a system of how you eat your string cheese. You know, I get so mad if my string is too thick. Like I like to really string it. Do you get mad at yourself, Jenna? Yeah, I like it to be like even strings. Okay, I open it and just bite it off.
当瑞安说，哦，你直接咬就行了。你就是，你知道的，你别把它一条条撕开。我太喜欢了。其实那是托比对瑞安说的。我知道你直接咬就行了。我刚才说的是瑞安吗？对，你说是瑞安。噢，天哪，我太尴尬了。我为我自己感到尴尬。拜托，我们会发布更正声明的。安吉拉，你是怎么吃手撕干酪的？你是直接咬还是顺着纹理撕着吃？我顺着纹理撕着吃。我撕着吃。哦，这说明了我们的一切。你可能非常死板，你吃手撕干酪有一套系统的方法。你知道的，如果我的干酪条撕得太厚，我会生气的。比如我喜欢把它撕得很细。你对自己也会生气吗，珍娜？对，我喜欢把它撕成粗细均匀的条。好吧，我打开它然后直接一口咬掉。
This says everything about us. I feel like I don't have time to string it out. Guys, how do you eat your string cheese? Do you string it or do you bite it? Or do you bite it? Jenna's a stringer. I'm a biter. I'm going to do a poll and we'll tell you the results. Okay. So Michael eventually makes it into the bathroom and then you overhear him falling into the toilet, demanding that Pam help him, demanding that Ryan help him. This was all basically scripted except for, it was in the script that Michael is supposed to say, get Ryan. But then Steve improvised, he needs to lift me and he needs to clean me up a little bit,
这说明了我们的一切。我觉得我没有时间把它一条条撕开。伙计们，你们是怎么吃手撕干酪的？你们是撕着吃还是直接咬？还是直接咬？珍娜是个撕条派。我是个直接咬派。我要发起一个投票，然后把结果告诉大家。好吧。所以迈克尔最终成功进了洗手间，然后你无意中听到他摔进马桶里，要求帕姆帮他，要求瑞安帮他。这些基本上都是照着剧本演的，除了，剧本里写的是迈克尔应该说，去找瑞安。但接着史蒂夫即兴发挥说，他需要把我拉起来，他需要帮我稍微清理一下，
bring a wet towel. And I think you can see Paul start to break at the end. Oh, no, you totally can. Right? For sure. I watched the scene a few times because I was like, Paul is breaking. Paul is breaking at nine minutes, 46 seconds. He starts to laugh and he turns away from camera and kind of leaves. He does. And then the camera, because our camera guys would do this quite often for us when they would see that we were starting to break, they'd whip away from us. They would. So he whipped, oh, the camera guy whipped to the door. But I think the thing that did him in was when you hear Michael fall for the second time, because that was also not in the script. And I think it was too much for Paul. Well, Steve was in there clanging around, like making noises and
拿条湿毛巾来。我想你能看到保罗在最后开始憋不住笑了。哦，不，你绝对能看到。对吧？肯定的。我把这个场景看了好几遍，因为我想，保罗快笑场了。保罗在9分46秒时笑场了。他开始笑，然后把头转开背对镜头，差不多要走开了。他确实这么做了。然后镜头，因为我们的摄像师经常会为我们这么做，当他们看到我们开始笑场时，他们会把镜头猛地从我们身上移开。他们真的会。所以他猛地，哦，摄像师猛地转向了门。但我认为真正让他破功的是，当你听到迈克尔第二次摔倒的时候，因为那也不是剧本里的。而且我觉得这对保罗来说实在太好笑了。好吧，史蒂夫在里面乒乒乓乓地乱撞，发出各种声音和
stuff. It was very funny. All right. So next, Jim and Pam are out in the bullpen and they're discussing Dwight. And this is when Michael busts in and asks people if they know what it's like to have a disability. He's ticked off. I remember shooting that scene. He is so angry now that no one is taking care of him or treating him special. And a lot of fans mentioned that one of their favorite lines is Stanley's line when Michael says, what does this look like to you? And Stanley says mailboxes, et cetera. And then, and then Steve does that thing that I love where he's like, shut it. Yes. That's Steve right there. So, you know, at the end of that scene, Dwight turns to Creed and says, dad, that was added on the day. That was an improv on the day. It was
诸如此类。非常搞笑。好吧。接下来，吉姆和帕姆在办公大区里，他们在讨论德怀特。就在这时，迈克尔冲了进来，问大家知不知道身有残疾是什么感觉。他气坏了。我记得拍摄那个场景时的情景。他现在非常生气，因为没有人照顾他，也没有把他当成特殊人群对待。许多粉丝提到，他们最喜欢的台词之一是斯坦利的台词，当迈克尔问，你觉得这看起来像什么？斯坦利说，邮箱，等等。然后，然后史蒂夫做出了我最喜欢的那个动作，他说，闭嘴。是的。那绝对是史蒂夫本色。所以呢，在这个场景的最后，德怀特转向克里德说，爸爸，那是当天临时加的。那是当天即兴发挥的。它
probably an alt. They would do that to us sometimes. They would have alternate endings to scenes. In the script, Dwight was supposed to pick up his phone and say hello, even though it didn't ring. Well, Creed being his dad is way better. Perfect. Perfect. All right. So this moves us into the conference room meeting where Michael has hung a bunch of photos of disabled people on the wall. Icons. Icons. Yes. Including two pictures of Tom Hanks. Tom Hanks in Forrest Gump and then Tom Hanks in Big. Yeah. But he thinks it's in Philadelphia. And then there's like a debate that it's definitely big. It's definitely big, but he says it still counts because he became a man overnight, which is a type of disability. 11 minutes, 56 seconds, tracking Mindy.
可能是一个备选台词。他们有时会这样对我们。他们会为场景准备备选结局。在剧本中，德怀特本应该拿起电话说喂，即使电话根本没响。好吧，克里德是他的爸爸这个设定要好得多。完美。完美。好吧。所以接下来我们进入了会议室会议，迈克尔在墙上挂了一堆残疾人的照片。偶像。偶像。是的。包括两张汤姆·汉克斯的照片。汤姆·汉克斯在《阿甘正传》里，然后是汤姆·汉克斯在《飞越未来》里。是的。但他以为那是《费城故事》。然后就产生了一场辩论，说这绝对是《飞越未来》。这绝对是《飞越未来》，但他却说这依然算数，因为他一夜之间变成了成年人，这是一种残疾。11分56秒，捕捉明迪的镜头。
Her hair looks fantastic. Her hair is fantastic. I have it on a note card, but it is half up and half down. It is. It's not full down. Her sweater, she's got a little bit of a v-neck. Yeah. This is not, we're not up to her chin with these like turtleneck blouses anymore. Paisley tops. She does have a paisley skirt. Speaking of hairstyles, Jenna, I wrote about my hair in my journal for this episode. I'm just, what? Listen, lady, if you had had to wear a tight bun with a gazillion bobby pins poking you for like every day, if you're something change, you might write about it. And I did. So here we go. This is what I said on a small note. I for once like my hair in this episode. Angela always wears the crazy braids, the buns,
她的发型看起来太棒了。她的发型太棒了。我有把它记在便签卡上，那是半扎半放的发型。确实如此。不是完全披散着的。她的毛衣，她穿了一件有点V领的衣服。是的。这不是，我们不再穿那种高领上衣把脖子包到下巴的风格了。佩斯利花纹上衣。她确实穿了一条佩斯利花纹的裙子。说到发型，珍娜，我在这集的日记里写了我的发型。我只是，什么？听着，姑娘，如果你每天都得梳一个紧紧的发髻，扎着无数个扎得你生疼的发夹，如果有什么改变的话，你可能也会写下来的。我确实写了。所以，来吧。这就是我在一个小纸条上写的内容。我破天荒地很喜欢这一集里的发型。安吉拉总是梳着疯狂的辫子、发髻、
the ponytails, but I guess being in a relationship has made her step it up a little. Ooh. I like that backstory. I got to wear my hair down. You did. And I was really excited. It had a little bit of a bouffant. I actually thought your hair looked really pretty in this episode. I have to say, I'm now, I was teasing you about writing in your journal about it, but I mean, yeah. Well, it was journal worthy. Thank you. It was the first episode that I didn't have my hair up in any way. No. So I wrote about it. Yeah. It's very nice. So now at 12 minutes, 20 seconds, we meet Billy Merchant, who is played by Marcus York as we discussed. And he is the property
马尾辫，但我想谈恋爱让她稍微有所提升。哦。我喜欢这个背景故事。我终于可以把头发放下来了。你确实放下来了。我当时真的很兴奋。头发甚至有点蓬松。我其实觉得这一集里你的发型看起来非常漂亮。我必须得说，我现在，我之前还拿你在日记里写这个开玩笑，但我的意思是，好吧。好吧，这确实值得写进日记。谢谢你。这是我第一次没有把头发梳起来的一集。没有。所以我把它写进去了。是的。非常好看。那么现在在12分20秒，我们遇到了比利·莫昌特，正如我们讨论过的，他由马库斯·约克饰演。他是个物业
manager. Yes. And he's here to just tell us information, right? About the parking lot. Tell us not to block the loading dock. Even if we have our hazards on, she just wants to tell us some stuff about the building. Right. Some of the building rules. And you said Michael sees this as an opportunity. Yes. Because Billy is in a wheelchair, Michael has decided that he's pretty sure Billy is going to lecture us about the proper way to treat disabled people and back up the fact that Michael has been so wronged. Oh, Michael's been so wronged, right? Mm-hmm. So Marcus said that they really stuck to the script, him and Steve for the scene, but then Steve threw an improv at him. I think I know what it is. Yes. So he said that Steve said,
经理。是的。他来这里只是为了告诉我们一些信息，对吧？关于停车场的事。告诉我们不要堵住装卸区。即使我们亮着双闪灯，她只是想告诉我们一些关于大楼的事情。没错。一些大楼规则。而你说迈克尔把这看作是一个机会。是的。因为比利坐着轮椅，迈克尔断定，他确信比利是要来向我们训话，教导我们对待残疾人的正确方式，以此来支持迈克尔觉得自己受到了天大的委屈这一事实。哦，迈克尔受到了天大的委屈，对吧？嗯哼。所以马库斯说，他和史蒂夫在这个场景中真的非常贴合剧本，但接着史蒂夫向他抛出一个即兴发挥。我想我知道是什么。是的。所以他说史蒂夫说，
well, you know, we have a lot in common. And then he says, I'm going to stop you right there and leave. That's all scripted. Yeah. But then Steve improvise, who me? And Billy goes, no, me, right now. He like improvised that right back. And I was like, that was great, Marcus. That was so good. Marcus said that he wasn't like ready for that improv. Like he wasn't sure. He said, you know, when you guest star on a show, you don't know, did they stick to the script? Yeah. He had heard that we had a lot of improv background and things like that. But he said that Steve just kind of threw that and then he just reacted. And that's like something he remembers as being really fun. Well, when Steve says that line, you know what? We aren't that
嗯，你知道的，我们有很多共同点。然后他说，我要就在这里打断你并离开。那是全按剧本来的。是的。但接着史蒂夫即兴发挥说，谁，我吗？而比利回答说，不，我，就现在。他立刻即兴回了这么一句。我当时就想，太棒了，马库斯。太好了。马库斯说他当时并没有准备好应对那个即兴发挥。就像他不太确定一样。他说，你知道的，当你作为客串明星出演一部剧时，你根本不知道，他们是严格按剧本演的吗？是的。他听说过我们有丰富的即兴喜剧背景之类的。但他说是史蒂夫随口扔出了那么一句，然后他就顺着反应了。而那是他记忆中觉得非常有趣的一段经历。好吧，当史蒂夫说那句台词时，你知道吗？我们其实没那么
different. When I clamp my foot on the George Forman grill, you see Mindy put her hand up to her mouth. And then you see me full on laughs and turn to rain and rain smiles at me. Yeah. No, the front row. The front row lost it. The front row lost it. I have both of those. I'm like, Jenna, you completely break. Mindy, I expect to. I expect to see Mindy's hand cover her mouth, but you don't even hide it. I don't. You just turn and start laughing. Well, Brian is staring at the floor. Brian is Kevin. You're having a hard time. He has got just like this laser focus onto the carpet, which seems also unnatural. And I think he's doing it. No, he's also probably biting the inside of his mouth or inflicting some kind of
不同。当我把脚夹在乔治·福尔曼烤盘上时，你看到明迪把手举到嘴边。然后你看到我直接笑喷了，转向雷恩，而雷恩对我微笑。是的。不，第一排。第一排彻底破功了。第一排彻底破功了。这两幕我都注意到了。我当时想，珍娜，你完全笑场了。明迪，我倒不意外。我本以为会看到明迪用手捂住嘴，但你连藏都不藏。我才没有。你直接转过身开始大笑。好吧，布赖恩正盯着地板看。布赖恩就是凯文。你当时处境艰难。他简直就像是把镭射般的视线死死钉在地毯上，这看起来也极不自然。而且我觉得他这么做是在。不，他大概也是在咬着嘴唇内侧或者对自己施加某种
pain on himself. So he doesn't laugh. I wanted to point out that I think it's really sweet how the director chose to put rain and I next to each other in that conference room scene. I would normally sit next to Jim, but I sat next to Dwight because Pam and Dwight are friends. Yes, they're friends now. Also in the scene, we learned that I guess Michael brushes his teeth for 10 seconds. 10 seconds. Wow. Okay. So next we go to a scene with Michael and Ryan, and Ryan is delivering him some pudding. Chocolate pudding. It's revealed that Ryan ground up some aspirin and put it in the pudding. And so there's been this runner where Michael really, really wants some fresh yams. And Ryan can't seem to find them anywhere. He asked them
痛苦。这样他就不会笑了。我想指出的是，我觉得导演选择让我和雷恩在那个会议室场景中坐在一起真的非常贴心。我通常会坐在吉姆旁边，但我坐在了德怀特旁边，因为帕姆和德怀特是朋友。是的，他们现在是朋友了。同样在这个场景中，我们得知迈克尔刷牙的时间大概是10秒钟。10秒钟。哇。好吧。接下来我们来到一个迈克尔和瑞安的场景，瑞安给他送来了一些布丁。巧克力布丁。结果发现瑞安把一些阿司匹林磨碎放进了布丁里。所以这里有一个延续的桥段，迈克尔非常非常想要一些新鲜的山药。而瑞安似乎到处都找不到。他问他们
if he found them in Carbondale, which is where he found the pudding at a gas station in Carbondale. Van question from Grelit, does a gas station in Carbondale always have fresh yams? I wanted to find out. I would think that no gas station had yams is I feel like Ryan isn't really trying that hard to look for these yams because I think if he just went to the grocery store. Carbondale is about 25 minutes outside of Scranton. Ryan hits a number of the sort of surrounding counties on his search for the yams. So I really looked hard and I could not find a gas station with yams in Carbondale. And most of them didn't even look like they had quick shops. Like maybe you could get gum, but some of them I felt like I couldn't even get a cup of coffee.
是否在卡本代尔找到过，他在卡本代尔的一个加油站找到了布丁。来自格雷利特的粉丝提问，卡本代尔的加油站总会有新鲜山药吗？我想去查证一下。我会觉得没有任何加油站会有山药，我觉得瑞安其实并没有那么努力地去找这些山药，因为我觉得如果他直接去杂货店的话。卡本代尔距离斯克兰顿大约25分钟车程。瑞安在寻找山药的途中去了周围的好几个县。所以我真的很仔细地找过，但我在卡本代尔根本找不到有卖山药的加油站。而且其中大多数看起来甚至不像有便利店。也许你能买到口香糖，但有些地方我甚至觉得连杯咖啡都买不到。
If you live in Carbondale, Pennsylvania, let me know. And if there's a gas station near you that sells yams, will you tell us? We'd love to know. Jenna, I have a question for you. What is it? How do I say this? Yeah. Did you ever think that you would stay up late looking for yams at gas stations in Carbondale? No. Also, you would Google map looking for yams in Carbondale? This is the kind of stuff we do for you guys. I'm allergic to yams and sweet potatoes, by the way. So even if I had found them, I could never do anything for myself with this information. This was all for you. All for you. Next in this episode, Dwight collapses. He needs to go to the hospital. And while we're walking to the elevator, Dwight says, it smells like chicken
如果你住在宾夕法尼亚州的卡本代尔，请让我知道。如果你家附近的加油站有卖山药，能告诉我们吗？我们很想知道。珍娜，我有个问题要问你。什么问题？我该怎么说呢？是的。你有没有想过自己会熬夜到深夜去卡本代尔的加油站找山药？没有。而且，你还会用谷歌地图搜索卡本代尔的山药？这就是我们为你们做的事。顺便说一句，我对山药和红薯过敏。所以即使我找到了，我拿着这些信息也什么都做不了。这一切都是为了你们。全为了你们。接下来在这个场景中，德怀特晕倒了。他需要去医院。当我们在走向电梯时，德怀特说，闻起来像鸡
soup. And Pam says, I know that was improvised. The amount of scripted words that they had for us did not get us to the elevator. So they told us just say some stuff. And I loved shooting the scene with rain. It was so much fun. It looked like it. It looked like you were having a good time. I really liked it. Also, I think he improvised that line where Jim says, what are you doing? And he says making Vietnam sounds or something like that as he's falling on the couch. Yes. But I did want to say something that was not improvised that's in the script is the water bottle that Jim picks up off of the plant and then is spraying him. That was in the scene. Well, I have a question. Yeah. At 15 minutes, 25 seconds. Yeah. Why? Why do they have to go in Meredith's van?
汤。帕姆说，我知道那是即兴发挥的。剧本留给我们的台词量根本不够我们走到电梯口。所以他们告诉我们随便说点什么。我很喜欢和雷恩一起拍这场戏。太有趣了。看起来确实如此。看起来你们玩得很开心。我真的很喜欢。另外，我觉得吉姆问“你在干什么”的那句台词也是他即兴发挥的，他说他在倒在沙发上时发出类似越南战争的声音或者别的什么。是的。但我确实想说一句不是即兴发挥而是剧本里写的东西，那就是吉姆从植物上拿起并用来喷他的那个水瓶。那本来就在场景里。好吧，我有疑问。是的。在15分25秒。是的。为什么？为什么他们非得坐梅雷迪思的面包车？
So many fans wrote in about that. Why couldn't they go in Jim's car? I get why Michael can't drive. I get that Dwight can't drive. But Jim, why didn't Jim say Meredith? That's fine. I don't want to ride in your gross van. I'll take my car. Here are his choices. Go in Meredith's van or put Dwight and Michael in his car. Dwight has already thrown up. I mean, I don't know. Would you put them in your car? Yes. I would rather drive my car, an injured person in my car, where I know my car. Meredith's van is a hot mess. But because they took Meredith's van, they had that great funny scene of Dwight trying to drink the rum in the backseat. Oh my gosh. So John has said in interviews that that was one of the hardest times he's ever laughed on the show was filming those Meredith
好多粉丝写信来问这个。为什么他们不能坐吉姆的车？我懂为什么迈克尔不能开车。我懂德怀特不能开车。但吉姆，吉姆为什么不说梅雷迪思？没关系。我才不想坐你那辆恶心的破车。我自己开车。他的选择有这些。要么坐梅雷迪思的面包车，要么把德怀特和迈克尔塞进自己的车里。德怀特已经吐过了。我是说，我不知道。你会把他们塞进你的车吗？会。我宁愿开我自己的车，把一个受伤的人放在我的车里，至少我对自己的车很熟悉。梅雷迪思的面包车简直是一团糟。但因为他们坐了梅雷迪思的面包车，才有了后面那场非常搞笑的戏，德怀特试图在后座上偷喝朗姆酒。哦天哪。所以约翰在采访中说过，那是他演这部剧时笑得最痛苦的一次，就是在拍摄那些梅雷迪思
van scenes. Well, I think these three guys, whenever they get in a car together, they lose it. Have you seen all the outtakes of them laughing their butts off? Yes. Like in these cars? And also, I think that John, it wasn't Jim, that was John with that spray bottle. Oh, he had too much fun with that. He had too much fun with that. We can't end this episode without me talking about one of my favorite things that Michael does is when he explains something that we all know, but he explains it to you as if he's the person that invented it or he's the only one that knows it. Shotgun. Oh my gosh. So at 16 minutes, 38 seconds, he goes, the rules of shotgun are very simple and very clear. Whenever he does this stuff, I just live for it. I love it. I love it. In this episode,
面包车场景的时候。好吧，我觉得这三个家伙，每当他们一起坐进一辆车里时，就会彻底失控。你们看过他们笑得前仰后合的所有幕后花絮吗？看过！就像在这些车里一样？而且我也觉得，约翰，那不是吉姆，拿着那个喷雾瓶的人是约翰。哦，他玩得太开心了。他玩得太开心了。我们不能结束这一集，却不聊聊迈克尔最让我喜欢的举动之一，那就是当他解释一件我们全都知道的事情时，却把它解释得好像他是发明这东西的人，或者他是唯一一个知道这事的人一样。副驾驶座。哦天哪。所以在16分38秒，他说，副驾驶座的规则非常简单也非常明确。每当他做这种事情时，我简直就是为了这个而活着。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。在本集中，
we learn Dwight's middle name is not danger. It's Kurt. But fan question from Brianna, was Dwight saying his middle name danger scripted or improvised? It was scripted. We also learn in this episode, you guys, that Creed, as a teenager, was in an iron lung. He says he was in an iron lung. Not that he had an iron lung, but he was, what? Like he's in an iron lung. That's what they are. That's the thing. You went inside. Yeah, you went inside of a thing called an iron lung, I guess. I don't know how it works. I don't either. I did not deep dive on iron lungs. I loved it, though. I loved it. Jim's like, how old are you? Oh no, that was Michael. When Michael was like, how old are you? But anyway, we learned that Creed was in an iron lung as a teenager, which is hilarious.
我们得知德怀特的中间名不是“危险”。是“库尔特”。但来自布里安娜的粉丝提问，德怀特说他的中间名是“危险”是剧本写的还是即兴发挥的？是剧本写的。我们在这集中还得知，伙计们，克里德在青少年时期曾住过铁肺呼吸机里。他说他曾待在铁肺里。不是说他得过铁肺病，而是他当时，什么？就像他待在铁肺里一样。那玩意儿就是那样。就是那个东西。你钻进去了。是的，你钻进了一个叫铁肺的东西里面，我猜。我不知道这东西是怎么运作的。我也不知道。我没有深入研究过铁肺。不过我挺喜欢这个的。我太喜欢了。吉姆说，你多大年纪？哦不，那是迈克尔说的。当迈克尔问，你多大年纪？但不管怎样，我们得知克里德在青少年时期曾住过铁肺里，这太荒谬了。
I love in this episode that Michael takes off his microphone. Yes. This is the first time we go radio silent, right? I think so. That we point out that we're actually mic'd. We sort of break that fourth wall in that way. Yeah. I liked that. And then I love this scene. And this scene was not in the script. In our shooting draft of the script, they must have added this later. I mean, probably while we were shooting, but this scene where Jim calls Pam and Angela pops her head over to over here if there's any news about Dwight and Pam clocks it. And then Pam goes over to Oscar and tells Oscar, hey, Oscar, I thought you'd like to know Dwight's going to be okay. And it zooms in on your face. And you're so relieved. And you can tell your,
我好喜欢这一集里迈克尔摘下麦克风的举动。是的。这是我们第一次进入无线静默状态，对吧？我想是的。我们指出了我们其实戴着麦克风。我们在某种程度上打破了第四堵墙。是的。我很喜欢那个。然后我超喜欢这个场景。而且这个场景根本不在剧本里。在我们拍摄用的剧本草案中，他们一定是后来才加上这一段的。我的意思是，可能是在我们拍摄期间，但吉姆打电话给帕姆、而安吉拉探出头来听听有没有关于德怀特的任何消息、帕姆注意到这一幕的这个场景。然后帕姆走到奥斯卡身边告诉奥斯卡，嘿，奥斯卡，我想你大概想知道德怀特会没事的。镜头拉近到你的脸上。而你如释重负。你能看出你的，
you can tell your own love. I'm in love. I was worried about my man. One of the things I did, and we all did this in different ways as characters, if something interesting was happening at reception, even if it wasn't in my script that my character clocked it, I would just pop up and look over the partition. And the first time one of the camera guys caught me doing it, the writers loved this and that kind of became a thing. So of course, if Pam is on the phone about Dwight, I'm going to pop my head over, but this one was scripted that my head's there, that I'm listening in. And I remember one of the things they told me is that they're going to catch my head at the top. It's not a ton of time. Pam's going to look back over
你能看出你自己的爱意。我坠入爱河了。我在为我的男人担心。我做过的一件事，而且我们所有人作为角色都以不同的方式做过这件事，如果前台发生什么有趣的事情，即使我的剧本里没有写我的角色注意到了这一幕，我也会直接探出身子越过隔板去看。当摄像师第一次抓拍到我这么做时，编剧们非常喜欢这个，于是这差不多就成了一个标志性动作。所以，当然，如果帕姆在打电话谈论德怀特，我肯定会把头探过去，但这一幕剧本里确实写了我的头在那儿，我在偷听。我记得他们告诉我的其中一件事是，他们会抓拍到我探出头的瞬间。时间并不长。帕姆会转头看回来，
and then I need to like disappear, right? And so we were playing around with this. So in one take, when you look back over, I just dropped to my knees. Do you notice how quickly you really do? And that's the one I think they kept in because I just like dropped like a rock. And they thought that was really funny. The very end of this, it's the final shot of Dwight in the CT scan machine and Michael tries to put his foot in. That was not in the script. That was an improvisation by Mr. Steve Carell. Of course, of course. So we learned in this episode that Dwight with a concussion is actually really a likable guy. But he also steps out of his lane a little with Pam, he becomes a friend, Jim didn't like that. And then he gets
然后我需要立刻消失，对吧？所以我们在反复尝试这个动作。所以在其中一条拍摄中，当你转头看回来时，我直接双膝跪地了。你们注意到我动作有多快了吗？这绝对是他们保留下来的那一条，因为我整个人就像一块石头一样直接瘫倒了。他们觉得这一幕超级搞笑。这个场景的最后，是德怀特在CT扫描仪里的最后一个镜头，而迈克尔试图把自己的脚塞进去。那可不在剧本里。那是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔先生的即兴发挥。当然，当然。所以我们在这集中得知，脑震荡的德怀特其实真的是个挺讨人喜欢的家伙。但他在帕姆面前也稍微有点越界了，他成了朋友，吉姆不喜欢这样。然后他和医生在一起时抢了本该属于迈克尔的笑点，迈克尔对此很不高兴。我不知道，我觉得他在这一集中太可爱了。好吧，许多人指出，未来会有一些剧集延续帕姆和德怀特的友谊，而且剧透一下，最后德怀特称帕姆为他的好朋友之一或者最好的朋友。我知道。这真的太甜了。我绝对喜欢这些。每当帕姆和德怀特不得不组队时我都超爱。关于帕姆，有一点我觉得是真的，那就是不管德怀特和/或迈克尔多么惹她烦，她其实真的很爱他们。她确实如此。他们就像是她的疯狂表亲或者古怪叔叔之类的。但她是真的爱他们。她确实很爱他们。我不得不认为安吉拉可不这么想。如果安吉拉不喜欢你，她就是
the jokes instead of Michael with the doctor and Michael didn't like that. And I don't know, I thought he was so adorable in this episode. Well, a lot of people pointed out that there are going to be some future episodes that follow the Pam and Dwight friendship and spoiler alert in the end Dwight calls Pam one of his best friends or his best friend. I know. And it's really sweet. And I absolutely loved these. I love whenever Pam and Dwight have to team up. I think something about Pam that's true is that for as much as Dwight and or Michael annoy her, she really loves them. Like she does. They're her crazy cousin or zany uncle or whatever. But she loves them. She does love them. I have to think that Angela does not. If Angela doesn't like you, she doesn't
不喜欢你。她就是不喜欢你。我不得不认为，这大概会成为她和德怀特之间产生冲突的一个根源。如果德怀特说，嗯，你知道，帕姆其实挺，我会说，哦，帕姆，你知道，我，我要说，我觉得帕姆唯一可能不太喜欢的真正的人就是安吉拉。我知道。就像我觉得她，你知道的，但如果没什么好话可说，她对安吉拉就会选择什么都不说。是的，但我真的觉得他们互相看不顺眼。我觉得他们没有。这太搞笑了。如果你有DVD，想看一看这一集中一段非常精彩的被删减片段，我个人最喜欢的是吉姆和迈克尔在急诊室候诊室的那场戏。德怀特在里面。他们
like you. She doesn't like you. And I have to think that it was probably like a source of conflict for her and Dwight. If Dwight was like, well, you know, Pam was kind of, I'm like, oh, Pam, you know, I, I'm going to say I think the one person that Pam maybe didn't like was Angela. I know. Like I think she, you know, but she'll take that if you have nothing good to say, say nothing at all about Angela. Yeah, but I really don't think they liked each other. I don't think they did. We're just hilarious. If you have the DVDs and want to watch a really great deleted scene from this episode, my personal favorite is the scene where Jim and Michael, they are in the waiting room of the emergency room. They're Dwight is in the back. They're
在这个大厅里等待。我看过这个。他们在看肥皂剧。这真的逗笑了我。他们俩就被困在这个医院的候诊室里看肥皂剧。我太喜欢了。好吧，伙计们，这就是工伤。这就是工伤。安吉拉带着伤来录这期播客。她简直太沉浸式表演了。你觉得你会不会是在潜意识里为了“工伤”这一集也给自己弄了个伤？不，不。我觉得我不能。思维融合？我觉得我在进行尖锐吐槽的时候不能嚼口香糖。我当时在嚼泡泡糖爆珠。这大概是因果报应吧。我不知道。我不知道。我猜也许你是为了这期节目才这么做的。好吧，听着。谢谢。谢谢你。你今天表现太棒了。不客气。伙计们，下周我们将带着《秘密》回归，在这一集中我们确实极大地推动了吉姆和帕姆的故事线。
waiting in this lobby. I watched this. They're watching a telenovela. And it just made me laugh. They're just stuck in this hospital waiting room watching a telenovela. And I loved it. Well, guys, that's the injury. That's the injury. Angela did this podcast with an injury. That's how method she is. Do you think you subconsciously gave yourself an injury for the injury? No, no. I think I can't. Mind melt? I think I can't chew gum when I'm having a sassy rant. I was vinting popping gum. It's probably karma. I don't know. I don't know. I think maybe you did it for the show. Well, listen. Thank you. Thank you. You're excellent today. You're welcome. Guys, next week we'll be back with the secret where we very much do propel the Jim Pam Storyline forward.
迈克尔能保守吉姆在酒船派对上告诉他的那个秘密吗？秘密。秘密。秘密。我的舌头有点麻了。秘密。安吉拉的舌头下周就会好起来的。这是好事。到时候见。拜拜。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·皮弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的节目以及我们的特别彩蛋节目《糖果袋》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Ken Michael, keep the secret that Jim told him on the booze cruise. The secret. The secret. Secret. My side of my tongue is numb. Secret. Angela's tongue will be better next week. That's a good thing. See you then. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher, our sound engineer is Sam Peefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episodes Candy Bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
肯·迈克尔，保守了吉姆在酒水游轮上告诉他的秘密。这个秘密。这个秘密。秘密。我舌头的一侧麻木了。秘密。安吉拉的舌头下周会好起来的。那是件好事。到时候见。再见。谢谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·皮费尔。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听本节目的无广告版本和我们的彩蛋节目《糖果袋》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的 Stitcher Premium，请使用兑换码 OFFICE。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。